hi everyone it's joanna here guess what
we're playing with today
resistance band there are lots of
different types out there the one i'm
using today
is a tube type resistance band okay
obviously there's
this short resistance band which is
famous for booty workout and there's
this long resistance band which is like
a big long loop
which is almost similar to this so what
i love about this is that it has
different resistance okay so the
lightest medium
and heaviest depending on what body part
you're working on you can adjust the
resistance accordingly
and if you're feeling strong then use
all
three okay so this bed has traveled with
me to so many different countries it's
light it's portable and i can do a home
workout or even if i'm
outdoors at the park i can simply just
hook it onto a loop or even a tree
and basically treat it like how i would
in the gym by doing cable workouts
so it's extremely convenient you can do
a total body workout and that's what
we're doing today it's hold the body
strength workout
using a resistance band okay and this
has literally saved me
during lockdown just by doing my
strength training at home
[Music]
this is going to be a total body workout
that will be three seconds all right
the first circuit will be focusing on
lower body and the second circuit will
be targeting your upper body
and we're going to end with a core
circuit again
this is a strength workout so really
focus on engaging
each muscle all right so for the warm-up
i just want you to get used
to working with your resistance band
okay so remember that
the shorter the band is the higher the
resistance
it is okay the longer it is the lower
the resistance is
so depending on what intensity you're
going for you can adjust the bend
accordingly
all right so now let's step on the band
okay make sure that that they're both
equal now let's just start with a simple
squat so push your butt back
okay and as you come up pull the band up
okay
so squat down up pull
the band up remember to just gently grip
on to the handles okay
there you go so remember with resistance
band
the contraction is the most
important so hold it for at least two
counts
before releasing it if you're just doing
this
it's not going to work your muscles so
remember hold it for at least
two counts and release because
there's pretty much no resistance once
you release the band so hold it
and release good job up
and squat push your butt back
okay all right now let's get into some
shoulder presses
so step right at the edge of your bend
hook the bend
just right behind your arm and all i
want to do is bend your knees
press it straight up release
press it up okay so brace your core
up good job up
just getting comfortable with the
resistance band
we'll be doing all sorts of workout
right after this
all right now change side switch over
find how much resistance you want
for yourself press it up push your
elbows back
press it up back and up
okay give me two more
last one more press and
up okay now let's start with
the first workout which is a resisted
squat okay i'm just going to show you
from this angle so
like what we did just now but now what i
want to do is
hook the band behind you okay it's going
to feel
really tense right here okay and that's
what we want that's where you will
really work on your muscles
squat down up good
really tensing the bend up
push up okay squat down and
up so you are really pushing the bend
all the way up squeezing your glutes
pushing your butt back
up good job remember chest
up just like how you would do with a
normal squat but now we're adding more
intensity push up
and good job
in and breathe out feel your legs
working
and your glutes back
and up good job can you feel that
tension
good okay release it now
it's going to be a reverse lunge with a
single arm shoulder press okay
like what we did just now remember that
press same thing
but now we're going to add a reverse
lunge so remember step back press it up
forward tap back press
forward and tap press it up
and release remember to keep your
front knees slightly bent
step and press
pushing through your heels
step good job keep going
step back press
and up show the burn
let's work on one side and we'll change
right after this push it up one more
up and change oh
left shoulder is burning okay now
change side on your right hook the bend
just right behind you
remember to lunge back so again adjust
the intensity
ready press up down
up and down brace your core
all the way up extend your arms
all the way straight and
press up good job
oh my heart rate is rising
and pushing back find your balance
so this is a really good total body
functional strength training press
up back down remember to push
through your right heels
and back down
and good job okay
oh a lot more interesting exercises
coming up
okay now lie down on the floor
depending on how strong your resistance
band is
what you can do is fold it into half
place it around your hips
okay press it down we're going to do a
simple glute bridge
but i want you to add that resistance by
pressing
the bend and pushing the band
up okay so really pressing it down
fighting against it push it up
squeeze push
all right remember to place your hands
down
push and up
okay up can you feel
your butt working hold it for two counts
right at the top
and lower it back down hold it
and back down all right i'll come back
up okay glued
reach kick okay this is one of my
favorite workout
so what i'm going to do is place the
band
just along your feet
place the band down and now just kick it
back all right holding on to the handles
kick it back squeeze two counts
knees in back good job
just like a glute bridge and now with
the additional resistance push
squeeze feel the squeeze right at the
peak and release slowly release
don't just let it go because it might
just snap on you
pull it release
push and release
and good job okay now i'm gonna turn the
other way
change side all right so right leg
it might take you some time hook it
oops
all right just gonna stand up right here
hook
it okay squeeze it back
in push it
and in good job contraction
right at the top remember the rep
that counts is when you really contract
and hold it right at the top
do not rush through the workout make
every rep
count
push it down breathe out
as you squeeze your glutes right
up release push
release and push oh my gosh
okay guess what let's repeat
the entire circuit once more all right
so
remember the resisted squat we're going
to do the same thing
keep it really tight ready
down up tight push your butt back
up and
up keep the resistance really tight
push your butt back squat all the way
down
and squeeze good job
chest up knees in line with your toes up
push it down
oh my legs absolutely burning who knew
just with a piece of really small
equipment
it can really help you to progress in
your workout and to take it
to the next level all right good job
okay now let's get into reverse lunge
with shoulder press okay so remember
choose your tension
step in if you want more resistance okay
ready step back push up tap in
up and in
press up in
and up
breathe good job look at one focal point
feel the work on your left leg your
front
leg and squeeze
into your glutes working on your
shoulders at the same time
push
press up straight up
a few more i am on fire
and back down okay
are we ready to switch side
bend just right behind
your arm ready step back
push up good job remember
hold it for two counts one two release
don't rush release and breathe
out as you come up
in and breathe out
if you can try to get your knees to
gently tap the floor
lunge as low as you can for a deeper
glute engagement press up
up and back
okay remember your knees should not go
over your toes
back down oh my gosh oh
i am absolutely dying okay lie
down onto the floor glute bridge
remember to press
the resistance band into the ground
okay and lift your hips
off that's all simple movement
off good job add a resistance
push your hands into the ground and push
your glutes
against it up squeeze
one two three and release
push good job
push imagining that
that's a straight line across your belly
button
drive it up squeeze right at the peak
release
let's go strong glutes
let's work on our booty and up
okay all right a little bit of trick
here
place the band underneath your feet to
begin with
and now get onto all fours okay
and ready kick it back
in kick it back
good job
[Music]
kick it back in and back
okay point your legs back and your toes
down this is an isolation workout
for your glutes it's really important to
work on
isolation exercises if you want to grow
a specific part of your body okay
so push it back if you want to tone your
glutes work on
isolation exercises in
push good job can you feel the under
butt
on fire i know i can
last few more one more
okay absolutely drenched
okay place it and now get into position
ready kick it back
just push the handles into the floor
kick
kick good job
gaze onto the ground square your hips
do not rotate your hips too much square
your hips
kick good job
nice one straight line
flat back and kick
ah you are strong you're almost there
this is the end of your first circuit
and you will get a short rest
kick well deserved break
oh my gosh oh
okay that is the end of
your lower body circuit take a short one
minute break
keep us up hydrated and for the next
circuit we want to work
on our upper body sexy arms
sexy back and sexy shoulders so take a
short break
second circuit we'll be focusing a lot
on your shoulders
your arms as well as your back muscles
so we want to really target
all the small muscles and to really give
you a toned upper body alright
so the first workout is going to be a
row focusing on your back
so step on the band with both feet okay
so start with a narrow row pull
the band up close your elbows release
and elbows pointed out
pull it up so it's a narrow pull it back
to a wide row okay
focusing on your back but focusing
on different muscles our back is
huge okay it's actually a big muscle
group so there are
lots of different muscles that we should
work on
pull it roll it remember to bend from
your hips
roll it back elbows close spread your
elbows
roll it up squeeze spread
and up good job if you have a stronger
band
you can use it for this workout because
again
your back is a big muscle
group so it can pull more resistance
all right next workout shoulder muscle
okay
small muscle group so you only need very
light resistance
upright row so point your elbows out
keep the band close to your body
roll it up and then front raise
pull it to the front okay front raises
will be more challenging
up good so pull it close to your body
elbows pointed up
pull it away and in front of you
working on your side belt and your front
delts giving you those toned and
sculpted shoulders
up remember again hold for two counts
before releasing don't do this okay
this is wrong slow control
up good squeeze it
make every rep count up
squeeze pull good job
chest up and pull okay
now let's work on your biceps okay
lots of females we tend to neglect our
biceps but again
they are important as well so same thing
let's start with a
white curl and let's go into a narrow
curl your bicep
consists of two muscles okay so we want
to work
on both of them white curl
narrow curl really pull it white
and narrow if you want a stronger
resistance step together
right narrow good
there you go more work on the arms right
now
narrow pull it out wide
good job really targeted
muscle group isolation workouts are the
best
to target specific muscles
keep a slight bend in your knees white
and
narrow all right tricep extension
step right at the edge of your band
place the band
directly behind you okay keep your
elbows close
elbows pointed up pull it squeeze it
straight up
release it can you see that my hand my
arm
is always close to my head step it back
pull it up and back down so do not point
your elbows out elbows in
extend squeeze your triceps extend
good job okay pull it straight up
let's see how many reps you can get in
45 seconds
squeeze it straight up release control
squeeze
squeeze good job toning up
on the bingo wing area up
squeeze release one more up
and release okay right
let's change the other way okay step on
the edge of your band place the band
behind you directly behind you
elbows pointed forward keep the arm
close to your body
point release
and point okay look straight ahead keep
your body upright
squeeze and point
good job raise your core do not hunt
your body
squeeze two counts can you feel that
burn
right on your triceps that's what we
want squeeze
nice and control up
woohoo i love this kind of workout i
really love it when i can feel that
my muscles are on fire and that every
wrap
is a quality wrap pull it one more
come on let's go up okay now release
now grab both off
grab your resistance band okay grip
slightly in
okay keep it tight and all i want to do
is pull the band apart
towards your chest in straight arms
pull it apart okay that's all in
and apart so what are you working on
you're basically working on
your back muscles as well as your red
delt okay
apart squeeze bend your elbows slightly
squeeze working on your red belt
and pull it apart good job
okay for more resistance hold it even
tighter
cool very good all right
keep going and really pull the band
apart
squeeze point your elbows back
getting into that rear delt muscle
cool i love this good job
okay now let's repeat the entire circuit
once
more if you have a stronger band feel
free to use it for this back workout
alright
so step wide okay again
narrow which means point your elbows
back
squeeze it and
out in and
out okay i'm just going to show you from
back view pull it in
elbows pointed out in
and out good job squeezing into your
rhomboids
into your legs and out
row and out so remember
to bend from your hips
all right roll back
and out good job
sexy back let's go ladies let's go
a small band to really work on the
entire body
okay shoulders love hit relationship
small muscle group but it's so important
to work on your shoulders
upright row remember to keep the band
close to your bodies
your body elbow pointed out front
and up okay
drive it forward drive it up
and forward
up and forward so the upright row will
work
on your side more and the front
is going to work on your front delt
squeeze it up good job remember just to
gently
hold on to the handle okay
up point your elbows up
and forward remember elbows higher
than your palm
and good all right okay
biceps let's go biceps
so choose your resistance okay step
shoulder width apart with your toes
pointer forward let's go
white curl and narrow
okay so spread your arms out slightly
curl it out
keep it together curl it in
out curl same thing you can also do this
workout
using a dumbbell out pull it
all these exercises can also be done
using a dumbbell or if you want to
challenge yourself
you can even hold on to a dumbbell while
using the resistance band that's going
to be really challenging but you can try
it out
curl out in out
and in good job keep it really narrow
keep it really wide
one more out and in
okay are we ready for our triceps
okay if you want more resistance step in
further all right place the band
directly behind you
elbows pointer forward let's go squeeze
up
down up
and down release it slowly
fighting against the resistance that is
the whole goal to
fight against it push it back
up all right remember to keep your
elbows pointed
forward if you point it out you're not
going to be feeling it on your triceps
squeeze it brace your core stand tall
up good job
squeeze keep going
squeeze
up and good job okay
let's go the other side all right
step in bend directly behind you
raise your core suck your belly in ready
squeeze
breathe out as you
contract
breathe out good job
we're almost at the end of our second
circuit
your upper body circuit at the end of
this workout i want you to really feel
that
you've done a great and strong workout
for your entire
body okay keep going squeeze it up
back down up and down
let's go do not stop right now i know
it's hurting i know it's pulling
but let's fight against it let's keep
going
give me three more reps one
two one more and up
okay all right final
upper body workout standing chest pull
okay
choose your option i'm gonna just turn
behind so that you can see it
remember to pull the band apart pull it
apart
squeeze your traps
and your rear delt okay really squeezing
into your traps
and your rear delt hold it for two to
three counts
release remember to keep your arms
in line with your shoulders do not drop
it
or do not lift it too high up
all right straight in line
pull it forward
good job remember to relax your
shoulders
do not bring your shoulders up this is
wrong okay relax it pull it
pull it down chest up
just like this we're at the end of our
second circuit take a short one minute
break
and the final second is going to be a
short
core circuit using this resistance band
so keep yourself hydrated wipe your
sweat and
catch your breath
slow down don't move too fast
okay welcome back and this is your final
circuit working on your core it's going
to be a short circuit
only three exercises okay so the first
workout is going to be a
wood chop so step on the edge of
your bend step shoulder width apart with
your toes pointer forward
just like a squat position grab on to
the handle
place the bend just behind your elbow
okay
grab onto both with both hands squat
rotate and as you come up chop and twist
so down up and
twist so this is a really good workout
working
on your obliques so imagine you're
chopping a wood
twist squat push your butt back
push your elbows back rotate
and rotate all the way up big rotation
working mainly on your obliques
push it away so you're pushing the band
away okay if you're doing it with one
hand you're pushing the band
away with both arm hold it
pull it good job one more
pull and back down okay
now change the other side same thing
step at the edge of the bend
find a firm ground either one hand
or both okay twist
up rotate bend
and twist good job also rotation
breathe out as you come up
up again remember you're pushing the
band
away it's not using the strength of your
shoulders it's using
the strength from your obliques okay
push it away and rotate
with your hips and your core
up and twist good
rotate and squeeze
and up and good job okay
now let's get down onto the floor place
the bend
onto the sole of your feet
slowly come back down all right this
final workout is going to be a reverse
crunch okay
so just hold on to the band raise it up
lower it back down raise your core up
and down depending on the intensity of
your band
you should really feel this workout
point it and back down
so the bend in a way it's also helping
to support
your legs so it should make it
a little bit easier but still
challenging at the same time so lower it
back down
up don't touch the floor lower it back
down
and up
good job breathe
breathe into the contraction and slowly
ah come back up okay
final circuit let's get back
into wood chop okay so remember
the power comes from your hips
and the rotation ready up
push it away back down
up good really use your hips
and your torso to resist
against the band up
down up if you're more comfortable using
one hand
you can do that as well okay so find
what's more comfortable for you but
remember
the work should be on your midsection
squeeze
up give me one more
rotate and drop it oh my gosh
i can see the bend like against the back
of my arm
okay now place it back ready
strong torso strong core okay
up up
rotate
good job
breathe out as you come up
release all the energy push it up
and push it out remember just like a
squat position push your butt
back okay do not hunch
forward up twist
look to the side
and rotate
that's one more come on strong up
and slowly come back down final workout
okay both feet
hooking on to the bend slowly
lower your body down okay
find your comfort point lower it
bring it up lower it down
and bring it up
that's it up and down
control and control
okay final 20 seconds you got this
i know it's burning i know it's shaking
everything is shaking you have done
a solid 30 minute workout so
let's end this strung together
let it shake but we're finishing we're
finishing it strong
oh can barely talk one last one up
and just drop back down
okay slowly push yourself
back up all right guys good news
you are done you're done with this
just drop it aside okay now
let's just take this time to just
stretch it out a little bit
okay we've worked on our total body
starting from your lower body to your
upper body to your core
so now let's just step forward okay
reach up feeling the stretch on your hip
flexor
push the weight forward and push your
knees
forward okay and just look up
keep your back flat
and take this time to bring your heart
rate
down and now just rotate
twist look as far back as you can
again we're not rushing to go anywhere
just slowly bring our heart rate down
and just breathe into the stretch okay
do not fight against it it's not
fighting against it release
relax breathe into the stretch all right
now release change side remember
pushing your hips forward pointing your
knees forward
up good job
and just
give yourself a pat on your back you've
done really well
you've completed the entire workout
and now twist look as far back as you
can
feel the stretch
and now just slowly bring your knee back
and now let's get into
a plank position let's get into downward
dog
and just slowly walk the dog
driving your heels down to the ground
stretching your hamstrings as well as
your calves
so push it one at a time
okay and now just hold it
really get into that high mountain push
your back
and now slowly lower yourself down
into a cobra okay stretch it up don't do
this okay this is wrong
push it away push it look
up feel the stretch on your lower back
remember do not sink into your shoulders
push it away from your neck
and now slowly fold yourself into a
child's pose
and just breathe
your heart rate should be lowered right
now
so just breathe
and slowly come back up
all right very
very well done that was a solid 30
minute
total body strength training using just
a resistance
band okay in the future if you want to
challenge yourself you can always add
resistance band and also dumbbells into
your workout routine
these are all really small equipments
which you can keep at home
and do lots of different home workouts
to not only build your strength and
endurance
but to also really help you to tone up
and
lose weight so i hope you have enjoyed
this video i hope you've enjoyed this
workout
let me know in the comments below if you
want more resistance band workout
and i will see you in my next video okay
if you haven't yet subscribed to my
youtube channel then go ahead and
subscribe
give this video a thumbs up and do
share this workout on with your friends
as well and i will see you next time
all the best